good morning at 7 56 i'm john langler
breaking news this morning the la bonita
grocery store in the east valley has
partially collapsed let's get right to
hector mejia live at desert and eastern
with the latest information hector good
morning
hey there john good morning we just got
an update from clark county fire
department they tell us four people were
hurt one of them had to be pulled out of
this thankfully though for those four
injuries none of those are
life-threatening but this is the
situation happening right now at la
bonita supermarkets at d.i and eastern
it looks like the awning and part of
this building just came crashing down in
front of the main entrance some of the
roofing there on top of these shopping
carts
firefighters there working to remove
some of this rubble according to a
witness
some of the employees were able to get
out of the store through the back
because the whole front entrance is
blocked off this is the situation going
on right now we'll have updates
throughout the morning now let's send it
over to nate for an update on the
traffic situation